revenons un instant sur le succès d'hier
on vous a tout dit ou presque sur
l'appareil sur son gigantisme sur les
espoirs que l'avionneur fondent sur lui
mais voyons maintenant ce qu'a été cette
aventure aux commandes dans un ciel
dominé par les américains pendant des
années bien le consortium européen a
réussi à s'imposer david bowie 1972 dans
l'indifférence générale
un airbus décolle pour la première fois
de la piste de toulouse blagnac un avion
né d'une volonté politique français
allemand et anglais se sont réunis pour
concevoir un avion de ligne européen ce
sera la 301 avions gros porteurs avec
deux couloirs et des rangées de sept
sièges une réussite technique
le premier airbus a donc volé
aujourd'hui a bien volé trois ans et
cinq mois c'est ça après la date de
l'enfance etc est je crois un gros
succès mais l'avion a du mal à séduire
les compagnies aériennes en 1974
airbus n'a que six avions dans son
carnet de commandes personne n'y croit
jusqu'à ce que deux compagnies
américaines choisissent d'en acheter une
trentaine boeing est battu sur son
propre marché en 1979 l'a300 a déjà été
vendu à 256 exemplaires l'avion européen
remporte un vrai succès commercial
airbus se lance ensuite dans la
construction d'un autre avion beaucoup
plus petit l'a320 un avion
révolutionnaire qui se pilote à deux
avec un mini manche des commandes
électriques le tout entièrement contrôlé
par ordinateur
le problème est essentiellement de
convaincre la communauté des pilotes que
les commandes de vol électriques et le
manche le mini manche était quelque
chose qui allaitent être acceptable
d'emblée sans être entraînement excessif
immédiatement par l'ensemble de la
communauté des pilotes mais c'est
ensuite le premier coup dur pour airbus
la catastrophe d'habsheim près de
strasbourg en 1988 lors d'un vol de
démonstration
l'a320 devient malgré tout un best
seller vendu à plus de deux mille trois
cents exemplaires dans le monde
l'entreprise européenne devient rentable
et développe une gamme complète d'avions
conçu sur le même principe en trois
décennies
airbus est devenu le premier
constructeur mondial d'avions devant son
rival américain boeing
une réussite industrielle jusqu'au
premier vol hier de l'a380 devant plus
de 50000 personnes